this video is sponsored by liquid
IV more on them after the reaction
people citizens of the reject Nation it is
I Andrew Flash Gordon and this is my first
time hosting ever on a YouTube channel I'm so
nervous and scared I don't know how this goes
but I am joined by my co-host eron hello it is
me Mario and we are here to do a film called
love Simon I've never heard of this movie I do
not know what to expect have you ever heard of
this film I have heard of this film I don't know
much about it okay good to know well let us know
in the comments section what do you guys think of
this film what are you expecting on this reaction
that's what I want to know if you don't mind
leave us a like do all the YouTube things you
guys do we appreciate it and also want to give
uh thanks to prepper for editing down all these
highlights with uh you got all my superhero
references and everything it takes hours at a
time so special thanks to them wow is this your
first time on a YouTube it is also full length
Reaction watch along where you sync up with your
own copy where you join us on patreon it's where
we call you super sexy you get to watch the whole
thing with Aaron and myself and also you get to
watch John and Greg do a bunch of exclusive other
shows and with that we are ready to watch Love
Simon I'm just like you for the most part
my life is totally normal my dad was the
annoyingly handsome quarterback who married the
hot valedictorian and no they didn't peek in I
school I have a sister I actually like not that
I'd ever tell her that last year in 200 episodes
of chop too she decided she wanted to be a chef
good choice which means we're pretty much all
her test subjects now sence of the food's good
it's [Music] okay and then there's my friends
two of them I've known since pretty much the
beginning of time or at least kindergarten hey
is that the kid in uh Spider-Man homecoming the
one with Betty brand this year has been nothing
short of it is crazy it's like insane Jason
what no swearing he totally is I just storm
yeah drink way too much ice coffee and the
girl from 13 Reasons Why dreaming of college
and gorging on [Music] cars that's something
I would totally do counting down the days I'm
just like you I have a totally perfectly
normal life except I have one huge ass
[Music] secret he likes gardening nothing wrong
with that morning oh sorry I didn't realize you
were your sister's downstairs making some
L do pancake then should probably go eat
that great I'll be down in just a second
right after you're finished searching the
internet for lingerie photos of XII H uh peer
pressure all right finish up here you got me
it's look enough gardening tools sir father
it's like what's going to be more scary me
having to tell my parents about you know my
sexual preference or me battling T-Rexes and
velociraptors if you seen Jurassic world you know
what I'm talking about Aaron listen I don't think
dinosaurs Trump parental rejection that's true
okay these are incredible cornal pancakes with
Blackberry compound damn those look bomb those
don't look fire low key see you guys honey be
back lie it's nice having a sister for a
chef mine's a dietitian but she's a damn
good cook mine plays soccer Mine played soccer
Mine played soccer too hey morning it's Simon
I live I live right here I like your your boots
goodbye good conversation nailing you're you're
getting somewhere with him next time you can
ask him what his favorite color [Music] is oh
that's cool the craziest dream last night
Nick you had the craziest dream Alexandria
ship what's her name yeah David Beckham is there
with these two contact lenses and like blue one
and red one like he's like a sexy he had a dream
about a soccer player Color Me shocked have you
guys seen Creek Secrets today apparently Becca
Peterson got caught given Ryan o Donovan and
HJ in the pool that's the real reason they
drained it what's an HJ say it out loud for
those of us who don't know say out loud for
the people in the back hi can we get four I
coffees please I can tell this soundtrack is
going to be fire oh yeah it's giving teenage
angst already already got a lot of comic
book actors and actresses in this yeah you
got Electra you got him from Spider-Man you
got storm yeah sorry guys I can't help it I
see comic book actors I'm going to mention it
you know maybe it's something that you're not
seeing clearly like something that's like
right in front of your face what am I not
seeing no idea dang he must feel really lonely
having to hide that secret from everybody yeah
like while he does have friends he's still and
he's not yeah he's afraid he does I mean can't
be honest it's it's understandable cuz you don't
know how PE some people are going to react but
if they're really your friends they'll accept
you otherwise they're not your friends right
true still that fear though of course no no
no totally understand you don't want to lose
them it's an interesting you know Gap pose like
do I want to just hold in the secret and keep
my friends or risk telling them and losing them
mhm great choice on the cargo pants by the way
it looks like you got ganged by a TJ Max whatever
oh that's not cool wish Ethan wouldn't make it so
easy for them that was a funny disc though the TJ
Maxx line come on phone off there's a whole world
to look at you can look people in the eyes stop
for the Selfies you're not all that this is all
that that was a good show I understood that
reference it was a great show oh I see more
phones this guy clearly is a high school teacher
to to still be in high school I can't believe we
have to be Greg berlan CW directed it oh wow CW
verse you excited to rehearse with you later do
you know that Cabaret was actually based off
a play called I am camera and I am camera was
based off this novel called uh goodbye to Berlin
and that's great that's that's wonderful I think
she found that interesting bye Martin well being
a someone who comes up with so many non-relevant
uh references I'm the king of what he's saying
we cannot watch the affair as a family why not
because it's all about SX they should watch
Unfaithful it's a good one I don't think I've
heard of that one oh really that's a good one okay
you know what we didn't see last week's episode
of The Bachelor how did that guy even become the
bachelor it's a good family show well he's clearly
gay The Bachelor oh Dad so oh no I wonder why
he's afraid to tell his dad um yeah after this
i g show you one okay yeah yeah this highlights w
you know poor guy man yeah he's a man's his dad's
a man's man I mean he doesn't even understand
how disrespectful he's being sucks a that's
cute look at this wait wait wait this
is your 20th anniversary so I'm going
to be super real with you right now
this looks like a fourth grader made
it like a deeply averaged fourth grader deeply
averaged fourth grader it's like I worked on
this for 30 minutes how dare you say this
to me we just got to put in you know some
home video putting some better music this was
huge When We Were Young yeah yeah so was Bill
Cosby he has a point have you seen
the new post I'm never getting back
in that pool again wa no about the CL a gay kid at
school what yeah it's on Creek secret what of the
come out when does it take place you mean what
year yeah I think I saw 2018 I think okay who do
you think it is maybe it's Parker or I heard like
obsessed with it's me Simon sometimes I feel like
I'm stuck on a ferris wheel 1 minute I'm on top
of the world and the next I'm at rock bottom over
and over all day long because a lot of my life is
great but nobody knows I'm gay blue Anonymous man
I get it he's wearing a blue sweater ah good good
[Music] catch from my window one I see what you
guys did there see what you did
Greg bante you're not you're not
clever this guy is so endearing I love this
guy yeah no he's a very he's a very kind and
I mean so far of what we've seen of him he's
a very kind and nice Soul de blue I'm just
like for the most part my life is totally
normal the annoyingly handsome quarterback
who married the hot Val PE in high school
I have a sister I actually like this is
almost like the narration from the beginning
narration he was talking in blue ah except I
have one huge ass secret oh yeah I like
gardening isn't that what you said yeah
exactly you can say it but I mean
it's Anonymous at this say I love my
hose
you can't say it not even in text I understand
the idea of being judged it sucks it's a real
thing the idea of not being accepted yeah nothing
can anyone answer for me how we find the value of
Dy by DX what's the answer Aaron Degeneration
X there you go Simon Simon hey w-e West Greg
brante another superhero character I just found
a press on nail in my salad eat it it's good for
you it's protein ew can't text in the Halls how
many times have I told you that I can't have all
my students tendering it up that's my department
what I got a really hot day tonight why are you
telling him this Vice principles can't go on
dates that's gross we're people too Simon is
he being honest I think he is but he's a s lack
of boundary with his students yeah could I just
get my phone unfortunately I'm going to have to
keep it until after practice but you will get
your precious after that's dumb my precious my
precious I went to school at a time where cell
phones were not as prevalent as now I don't
is that an actual rule no in the hallway I
don't no that seems like it's [__] in class I
get but yeah like and he can't be the only one
using his phone all right that was Cal help me
that was that was a start that was a start Miss
Albright that was the biggest train wreck our
stage has ever seen and Rob and Brienne were
practically brutal honesty it'll take you
far in life yeah save the kissing all right
This Is War you're Nazis more anger boo I was
an extra in The Lion King and this is where I
am come on Aaron little impressed by
that I was impressed it's my Han Zimmer
impression where's my precious uh just here
for my phone oh of course you are he's got
like truckloads of phones you can call me AT&T
Simon I know that I'm hard on you I really do
you shouldn't say that it's only cuz I really
see myself in you very poor choice of words is
there something you want to say to me you
know my policy what does it say open door
policy U there's nothing you want to say nope
did he did he go through his phone it's feeling
like he went through his phone don't text and
drive that's time my cat got murdered I'm just
kidding I don't have cats I got asthma he's an
interesting administrator that's the reason I
can't breathe cuz my asthma not my allergies
did he message you he did secret huh is it
the same as my secret if it is who is it I'm so
curious do you think it's someone we've already
met maybe it's the gardener really probably
not I feel like it's someone who go obviously
someone who goes would be random if it was the
gardener The Gardener goes to the school he just
doesn't know it yet it's got to be someone
we've met right probably at this point and
honestly I can't even really explain why
deep down I know my family would be fine
with it at the end of the day it doesn't
really matter who it is I his patri though
patri when Ethan came out no one even cared
guys I have something to tell you I'm gay wow
really damn that's crazy what a
complete surprise too much CL like
this one recurring dream I kept
having about Daniel Radcliff I'm
a wizard I was obsessed with panic at
The Discord he's so cute he's so cute
he's then I realized it really wasn't about
the music well yeah he's okay it was my first
girlfriend I think in love with you damn
thank you be right back damn that's crazy
girl that's crazy too when you're like
not putting in any kind of effort and
a girl says I love you like that it's like
damn how about you how did you know warmly
Jack this is this is sweet though CU he can't
he feels like he can't talk to anyone so yeah
now he has someone to talk to about this stuff
anonymously your proudest moment happened in
middle school that would be pretty sad for
me I realized I like guys watching Game of
Thrones my friends were all holding their
breath almost did look like the gardener I
was crushing hard on Jon Snow Well I've never
told anyone about my Daniel Radcliff phase so
now we're even if I want to find you at school
I just have to look for for the Game of Thrones
fanatic it's a popular character especially at
this time when it's on the air yeah obviously
some of the things I've told you about myself
are things I've never talked about with anyone
something about you that makes me want to open
up and that's slightly terrifying you think
he's going to deduce the wrong person he might
Halloween's all about the Oreos with the orange
frosting in the middle oh yeah the orange frosting
in Halloween INF factual you going you look happy
I'm a little why why way I've been 10 or dat last
night bro like I'm not the guy I'm not the one to
tell this to he really likes to share information
with students about his personal life where are
your friends bro I don't know if he has that he's
not he's a nice guy but uh for Cabaret yeah take
care of his bread I wouldn't be surprised if it's
him he's been talking to oh okay okay putting it
in the rediction Hat your [Music] whbs H or not r
or maybe it's not him I don't think it is not at
this point Oreos man I love this Halloween one's
for the best oh I think it's him I think showing
the I think showing the guy is a mislead my mom is
going down to Orlando to deal with it which means
I get to throw a Halloween party awesome it could
be him but also Oreos are a very popular thing so
I'm not saying it's not him I'm just making an
observation Oreos are extremely popular nope
only one person likes Oreos Andrew only one you
assume so much risk when you throw a party in my
opinion see someone with orange Oreos Go full
in agreement on Oreos told you I said I didn't
say it wasn't him I just said I would I'm just
saying it was it's a very popular item I can't
stop thinking about kissing you Simon Simon oh but
that was in his head so was not confirmed oh damn
okay told you no I'm just kid I thought I was
so right for a second it could it it definitely
could be him he's a he's a candidate but my hair's
kind of like my thing I'm going to go get a soda
um you want anything oh gave him the look oh he
discovered whose email it was he knows a secret
hey um I used the uh computer in the library right
after you well I went to Gmail and it pulled up
your account and I uh read some of your emails
D why you doing it bro mind your own business
you knowsy ass so you be interested to know my
brother's gay M that wouldn't interest me to know
okay don't worry I won't show anyone I don't like
this did you print my emails or something no no no
no why are you blackmailing him I screenshot them
screenshotted my emails why would you do that why
would you why would you do that is so intrusive
and Despicable why the hell did you screenshot
my emails well you and Abby sua are good friends
what does that have to do with anything well I
need you do help me hook up with her and hang out
with her and stuff you're slimy he is so creepy
this dude are you blackmailing me sh I knew it
I freaking knew it you can help me yeah what if
I say no dude Jesus couldn't help you then the
whole world will know you're gay and reject you
forever I I just think that we're in a position
here where we can help each other out as home
you're slimy you're trash Brock you're trash Brock
do you understand that reference I'll give you
there it is it's Brock sir Edward Brock Jr it's
asking me if I understood a superhero reference
I would have shocked if you didn't get that me
the other day you asked me what I was wearing
for Halloween and I said I wasn't dressing all
right we're hearing his voice actor plays W West
truth is I didn't want you to know what I was
wearing because I don't want you to know who I
am maybe I was right I it it probably is him it
is him I'm just not ready for my whole world to
change I hope you understand yes blue I understand
man I feel for him this is so this is such a tough
situation especially when you hear everyone like
how everyone's chattering and talking about it too
people were just more in an accepting like talk
about it it's like okay if you want me to help
you with Abby you cannot eat that so you're going
to help yeah and you got to delete those pictures
but also the problem is he's got word of mouth
too he can mhm all right here we go and here we
go this is where the magic happens that is not a
place to bring women I've been dabbling in closeup
illusions I think he likes magic I don't know why
I would say that but I think just a guess I'm just
going to take a guess just little little small
one if you want Abby to like you what you have to
do is you have to make my name boret very nice you
like dudes tell me what part of me do you find the
hottest come on bro chill they don't want to read
your clothes I don't want your help in changing me
I want your help in getting happy to like me for
me okay so we got to change you just you're an
you're repulsive we need to change everything
about you do you want to go with my friends
and I yes so simple must be why they call you
Simple Simon nobody calls me that Martin that's
insulting this is my favorite time of the year
cuz it kicks off the three best holidays Aaron
shocking this is like a new level of laziness
even that's a great wig what the hell you didn't
get that at a Halloween store hey don't talk
about Yoko that way man cuz if you do yeah out
of the band Yoko Ono John Lennon and Yoko Ono
see I knew one she can't be Yoko what a woman
in his she should have dressed like storm to
meta two on the nose just meta enough she was
putting that into the universe that she wants to
be a superhero I uh I'm going to go make those
for some pizzas wait no wouldn't she already
filmed that at this point uh this is 2018 so
she did X-Men apocalypse in 2016 so yes oh okay
okay remember when we went to school dressed as
Charlie's Angels oh my God yes and Nick's
balls fell out of his booty shorts when he
like no the balls out the booty
shorts that's an image I will not
get out of my head now that's a
hilarious statement who's that
I invited Martin Martin Addison why is this
a make a wish situation wow Aaron and I are
displeased oh he said they don't want to
read your clothes what are you supposed to
be I am a Freudian slip oh Jesus hey here's an
interesting question I love Beyonce whates you
guys feel nostalgic y'all are on the different
wavelengths bro makes me feel very nostalgic I'm
cringing I'm cringing so hard I think Abby
is into him why is Nick still fighting with
Abby I don't know Martin maybe you shouldn't
have worn a dress hey John Lennon he got it I
thought he was going to dress up as an orange
Oreo oh uh I am post presidency Barack Obama
just chilling nice we could all dream of that
you need to let it go need to let it go when I
get drunken off or have a little liquid courage
then I I get up on the karaoke stage hey I want
to see that happen you've you've seen it at
Greg's birthdays I didn't I didn't go to the
last birthday party I wasn't here this past
year ah you missed out I was there two years
ago ah Abby is the hottest wonder woman I've
ever seen yeah [__] that I will let do to me
with that lasso oh I know man she'd make you
tell the truth you're not in it Abby are you
no she's cute but she's not really my type not
because she's black oh God stop it just don't do
that don't do that you don't have to it's okay put
put his foot in his mouth on that one oh [Music]
God I'm I'm cringing internally you can't ask
Abby out why not because she didn't tell you
about Jonathan you're ruining your friendships in
college uh-huh he's really experienced oh because
he hasn't been honest that's why he's not being
honest about they like each other he's trying to
ruin their connection for self-preservation and
then that's going to come out and there's going
to be a whole Fallout and then him being gay is
going to come out and they're like oh we accept
you and love you exactly hey Simon hey hey you
want to play uh b r yeah oooop o how about you
and me and then um Abby and Marton no no I
don't oh lord it's like why what have I done
to deserve this my God you guys just ear in the
same Vibe bro and that's okay you got to find
someone who is unto your Vibe see better right
good idea all you rain drop all right drop top
I have a feeling he's going to get so drunk that
he's going to let it out Martin that's interesting
[Music]
Theory hey Ram it's me jacqu I'm Jo h i
mean you can be on you can say that and if
it weren't him he would be like who the hell
is YC mhm like you'd still be protected from
your secret he's going to walk on him making
out with somebody then he's going to go yep
yep go oh as they do as the movies do I'm I'm
sorry I thought this was the bathroom a poor
guy though I guess it's not him still could
be he's just keeping up appearances could be
maybe as comes to turn with it not going to lie
that girl he was hooking up with was uh pretty
attractive and in real life she's not in high
school mother trucker you're you're oh you're
fun you're awesome you must be fun at parties
that's don't ridicule me in the comments she's
not really in high school in real life she's
probably like 24 25 got to cover your bases
yeah I bet she likes him and then he's
going to come out to her first I would
not be surprised by that look we're so close
oh my God I thought for a moment too she might
be a little interested in Martin but like he
is so as you say repulsive like I don't know
how anybody could like that guy he's got to get
a lot more mature just is just you know needs
some more self-awareness hey guys hey come talk
to look at this cute couple Aces uh well thanks
for you at least clean the shoes up my guy do
you ever feel weird all the time sometimes I
feel like I'm always on the outside snaps
snaps to that I was at that party and it
was fun but kind of felt like I was watching it
from across the room I don't know like there's
this invisible line that I have to cross to
really be a part of everything and I just I
can't ever cross it feel that way sometimes
too I feel you yeah sometimes I think it'd
be so much easier to be one of these people
who can just take a few shots and then hook
up with whoever's closest it's the best way
to go to a party I'm not a casual person what
kind of person are you I think I'm the kind of
person who is destined to care so much about
one person it nearly kills me me too uhoh
H uhoh oh she's having a moment he's not R
uh I just feel bad for her cuz she doesn't
know why he didn't yeah shair hit the same
same sentiment and I guess we all have secrets
I've been thinking about why I haven't come out
yet maybe it's because it doesn't seem fair that
only gay people have to come out why is straight
the default mom there's something I have to
tell you I'm straight I'm straight I like
girls you get that from your daddy side you get
that from your daddy side can't be sure this whole
being gay thing is forever maybe it's that there's
not that much of high school left and part of me
wants to hold on to who I've always been when I go
to college in Los Angeles I'll be gay and proud I
[Applause] [Laughter] [Music] promise somebody
yeah maybe not that gay I'll keep ruminating love
jacqu what what what happened you but love he like
oh no it's going to reject me cuz I put love oh
thought it was like linked to a certain account
or something that reveal red no cuz remember he'd
always edit it to like make it more casual yeah
anybody else Christmas in the Caribbean I'm going
to an unheated vacation house in the middle of
nowhere as is our leak family tradition paper
cut those hurt do you know where the bandages are
yeah why don't you show me do you mind showing me
it's not working I don't actually have a paper
cut I know that Martin you're a very bad actor
you cannot bring blue into this okay if he found
out that mimos got leaked he'd get totally freaked
why he never talked me that rhymed internet's a
freaky place to meet people Freaky Friday fre fun
movie Friday that's a fun movie you know Martin
was having trouble running his lines and we were
thinking we could go to Waffle House and go over
him Waffle House where do this take place on the
East Coast I would assume so we ain't got that in
California plus he said he was going to go to what
do we have here rosos we do have rosos you said
love if I were a betting man say you were drunk
emailing me during that last yeah see it's not
his Wally West voice anymore as for coming out
I know what you mean about wanting to wait till
college but our emails have inspired me I'm going
to tell my family so thanks shck it really could
be that Gardener guy I don't know it's not really
the point of who it who it is but just curiosity
I hope it's somebody we're definitely going to get
to see them by the end of this I'm sure we will
but again I feel like it was a mislead I still
feel like it's that dude you mean Wally West Wally
West the thespians rehearse hey guys what can I
get you or it's him oh it could be him we have a
Latin together I don't think so it's ly actually
we had uh bio together last year oh really Simon
right yeah sorry I don't um it's okay it was like
a big class and I have a good memory for faces
okay there we go oh there's a Vibe and much too
distracting and you never did any acting at your
old school no flattery will get you so far can
you give me my next queue though so why why did
you move here oh Jesus listen bro you need to
listen because my parents got divorced oh why they
get divorced Martin are you writing a book about
girls from a broken home in DC got got to chill
I thought that my dad was the greatest person on
the planet but it turns out that he's just a
sad tired loser who hates his job drinks way
too much beer and cheats on his wife I'm sorry to
hear that you deserve the father that you thought
you had oh my go tenderness actually don't ruin
it don't it up I want to hear you say I AB you to
so and an an incredible young woman and deserve
a goddamn superhero I'm not going to say that
Martin well um I won't stop until you say it I'm
cringing Abby here I hate this is an incredible
young woman please you're embarrassing her bro
that's right Abby is an incredible young woman
incredible young woman and deserves a godamn
superhero oh this working a godamn superhero
this is working wow I'm shook only in the movie
this would work only in a freaking movie dude
no way breakthrough yeah all right give me my
waffles now please please sit down that was a
cute moment though actually as much as I don't
like Martin that wasn't a sweet moment well uh
let's get back uh uhoh is she developing some
feelings possibly now could be could be could
be I'll be right back oh you can see oh she is
wow I'm surprised I'm shooketh were you in BIO
when they did that identifying leaves test and
uh Joel wissow at that poison ivy because Doug
fogy told him it was pot you see everything
don't you Simon Simon means the one who hears
spear means the one who sees you put that all
together I've got to get back inside and scrub
down some waffle irons I'll see you in there yeah
I'll see you he just got an email he's not blue
wait was he though doing stuff on the phone right
before he sent that or so my dad lying in tonight
for Hanukkah if you are thinking but he's just
thinking it's him welcome to navigating divorce
parents take holiday where you can get them and
my dad staying at the same crappy Motel as always
we'll do all our horribly awkward tradition
H do you think I'm crazy I think you're crazy
Brave again that doesn't confirm it him it's
just what he believes and since yeah yep okay
we're back at square zero honestly Martin used
to annoy the crap out of me but he's actually
kind of a cool person do you I've been mean to
ask you about your parents no I I don't mention
it a lot because it kind of M with my image girl
who is excited to start a new school senior year
M girl whose life didn't just end like 3 months
ago who's angry and sad all the time see it's not
just sexual preference things we keep within
don't want to share you still believe in love
maybe have you ever been in love I think so
is he going to tell her maybe he's going to
tell her he's going to say gay oh it's cool
first person he told nobody really knows and
I don't don't really want people to find out I W
I promise a that's so sweet respecting boundaries
you surprised no so you knew no but you're
not surprised do you want me to be surprised
I don't know okay well I love you a love you
too when he said are you surprised he said no
that was such a good delivery mhm there's no one
behind us you don't have to put your being safe
that's such a big step for him he told somebody
that's awwesome but also hearing that someone in
his friend Circle accepted it someone close to
him like I think that was also a big Revelation
and stepping stone for him as well that'll
probably Inspire him to tell other people
you inspired me I came out to my friend tonight
I never would have done that without you maybe
we should ride this bravery train and reveal
our identities I'm dying to know who you are a
take those steps man you take those steps that's
awesome I told my dad who's insanely awkward but
it's you who inspires me but I'm sorry I'm
just not ready for us to know each other's
identities damn but why I'm a fry shark yeah and
my name is Bruce shocking you're a good fry Shar
thank you thank you I like that I didn't uh I feel
bad for him yeah Simon since when does Abby find
Martin so goddamn funny I'm just going to tell
her that I like her and I've been thinking the
whole sexual experience thing it's not that
big of a deal actually I've been practicing
right I got this thing online it's really it's
called a pocket likes Martin no I hate this look
I I don't care I'm just I'm going to try wait
wait what about Leah what about Leah oh don't
do this don't be a bad friend Leah's in love
with you no she's not why are you setting him
up for rejection what are you doing I hate this
this is awful she blushes every time you come
into the room in factual you and Abby never
going to happen you and Leah oh you could be
in together you're being a bad friend so I have
something to tell you I like you Nick just asked
me to get dinner before the homecoming game he
came up to me and he's like do you want to go
get dinner right and I was like sure ab and
Simon and and he was like I was thinking it
could just be the two of us like a date that's
amazing I know you're into it all that stuff you
were talking about the night after bram's party
it was about you it's about you fool you cannot
be that naive my friend so you think I should go
out with him yes yeah yeah I promise you you're
not going to regret it it's going to be great
[Music] oh I assume you can't text at football
games either right no the principal's on it
he's going to take your phone there too wont
QB is insanely hot we can talk about stuff like
this now you know yeah I uh still haven't really
quite figured out how Simo do you think that that
quarterback is looking fine it's looking pretty
fine f f oh hey TR it's the Waffle House guy
Lyall ly uh I don't know could be I don't know
do you think he's I don't know okay well you
should talk to him I'm going to go get a coffee
oh so she knows about the emails then right
it sounds like no she just knows that she oh
oh she was asking do you think he could be okay
I thought she was asking do you think he could
be the email Guy no that's why I thought she was
inferring I'm glad you're here you are yeah cuz
I wanted to ask you something I was going to
ask you the other day are you shc he's going
to ask her about the friend what's Abby's deal
told you I told you I I know I called it like 4
seconds before he said it but poor guy uh I got
to go I see you dude you got to stop predicting
and thinking who you little birdie told me
you're in the May is that Mar is that Martin
met him yeah totally I figured out my next move
with the app great that's good for you Martin I
just wanted to run it by you real quick I've
been helping you for weeks and I am sick and
tired of helping you mess with my friends's lives
so why don't you just do that [__] that you did
at Waffle House that went great so so you're
saying I should go for it that was dinner it
was good yeah she wasn't into it that dumpling
place I told you about oh you know maybe you
could go with Martin messing with your friends
please stand for the national anthem oh can oh
my God no no please God please God don't do this
I had a feeling he was going to do this oh I I
don't want to watch I don't want to I don't want
to be here for this no God why everyone sorry to
interrupt interrup and I don't know if I can watch
this dude I don't know I don't know if my cringe
can take it Abigail cine Su just a short 3 and
1 half months ago you not only transferred into
a new new school you transferred your way into a
new heart belonging to me are you not yeah you're
uncomfortable too okay cool the 135,00 minutes
that we've spent together 135,000 31 I don't
know what to do with my body I smart talented oh
no I mean it takes a lot of Courage like not but
yeah it's embarrassing no well like used to say
y'all are filming it this man's ruining his high
school career will you go out with me no God
no this is cringe this is so freaking cringe
I am so sorry I don't feel that way about you o we
could still be friends you know are those doves oh
no oh sheesh hey no no she said no no don't okay
okay the cringe has passed nice try Martin and
way to go Martin you gave it a shot right yeah
I I spoke prematurely the cringe is it still
lives here it's taken residence that was terrible
don't worry people will get over it in a few weeks
oh the memes that would so go oh he's definitely
going to out you now that would so go viral 100%
I mean everything goes viral nowadays these are
some outdated memes even for this this time but
the sentiment is there Martin it's Simon want
to make sure you're doing all right I know it's
been tough since uh well you know since when
since you're publicly humiliated yourself went
viral I just want to make sure you're okay okay
hey it scared the crap out of me I'm drinking
eggnog and packing to go to my dad's cabin on
Lake Raven pretty sure there's a photo of it
on the wikkipedia page for middle of nowhere
I'm going to an unheated vacation house in the
middle of nowhere dude stop guessing who it is
you did say that it might have been him earlier
right did I I I think you did I'm pretty sure
you You' said it was like I've called everyone
but him sounds like you're going to need some
good music so I'm sending a list of the seven
best Christmas songs of all I love Christmas songs
Smokey Robinson and the Miracles Christmas every
day but the number one song you're going to
need don't say Mariah [Music] Carey Jackson
5 S hey have you seen it uhoh he outed you
Creek Secret so he screenshotted it that is
not cool dude he tried his best Simon spear
has a secret male pen pal because he's gay
dude really he tried helping you that's not
his fault right talking about this instead of
Martin Addison's homecoming debacle which was
actually kind of sweet trying to take the heat
off of himself I never thought I could hate this
character even more than I do right now but no
that guy sucked from the beginning well at the
D at the waffle place I'm like oh okay there's
a little that was still cringe I was surprised
that she was into that hi no the oh the sister
knows too I'm gay oh oh like what are you going
to do I don't know you could deny it why the
hell would I deny it nor I'm I'm I'm not ashamed
of it what the hell are you talking about sorry
and someone posted our emails please don't freak
out I need you to promise me you won't disappear
want to go for a walk yeah he just doesn't
just like get away from technology right
now I'm not a violent person and I do not condone
violence in any way but Martin deserves a nice
beating that guy was is trash did and has been
trash from the start of this movie this one
Sherlock there you go Bluetooth headphones
do you like the black you actually um I did
want to talk to you guys about about something
right now well let me guess you got somebody
pregnant knew it I'm I knew it he's got that glob
on him babe dude let him talk dude stop with the
jokes I'm gay honey oh the two parents different
reactions man I'm still me of course you are yeah
Simon oh the dad so you're gay which one of your
old girlfriends turned you was it the uh the one
with the big eyebrow or the one with the BRAC
can you ever shut the hell up I'm kidding it's
not funny yeah it's not funny dude please yeah
you're being so insensitive that is not a react
he's trying to yeah no I deflect or diffuse with
humor I came out to my entire family on Christmas
it didn't go great and I've been avoiding my
friends the whole break for all sorts of reasons
change is exhausting I feel like there's nowhere
to hide from all the newness of everything except
here with you I mean I'm happy he's able to to be
open and free you know but sucks how it happened
come sit down going to be late oh boy this is
going to be a tough first day for him I feel he's
isolating hey guys hey Simon We you to talk
oh about what he did now we're together that's
awesome they're mad at you though then we got to
talking about why it took so long Martin was the
one who wrote that Creek Secrets post about me
he told me that if I didn't help him get with
Abby he'd out me that's why I had to keep you
guys apart so you made up a bunch of lies I'm
not a piece of meat Simon you know how hard it
was for me to start over I trusted you I know I
messed up okay but I I knew you were in love
with Nick and I thought that maybe just stop
it no no no no no no you're insanely stupid
Simon I was never in love with Nick I was in
love with you I can deal with you being gay
sigh but you set me up to get my heartbroken
when you thought I was in love with Nick and
that just makes you cruel he was scared self
reservation uh for the uh for the record when
I was saying that we have a lot in common you
know I wasn't really oh shut up did you J me
because you think I look like a guy oh no broke
up with you because you don't look like a guy that
makes sense hey oh that is the guy from Cobra Kai
yeah hit him I'll take it from here hey Miss Au
don't hate Miss All Bright me we're not friends
you're not going to break and this is complete
harassment you know what you're about to be
suspended for so long that by the time it's over
you're going to be the fat bald Unhappily Married
wildly mediocre nobodies you're destined to be
damn you can't talk to us like that actually I
can and you know why because you're just those
two [__] that did that shitty thing in front
of the whole school nobody feels sorry for those
[__] especially me go you go mik Dro you might
have just got fired but you go why does Mr worth
have to talk to us can't we just let this [__]
go he wasn't even part of this why why is he
there hey I'm sorry Ethan none of this ever
happened when just you were out you know what
they say one gay is a snooze two is a hilarious
hate crime you could have told me you were gay I
guess I didn't think we had very much in common
you're telling me Simon it's not like your all
hoodie wardrobe rocks my world you've been out
since you were 16 and always seems so easy for you
easy my mom still tells my grandparents about all
the girls I'm dating when we go over to their
house for dinner jeez dang she says it's cuz
they're old and religious it's just easier that
way okay these gentlemen have something that
they would like to say to you I am pieces of we
are pieces of craps we are boo boo incarnate we
respect Simon and Ethan's choice to be boyfriends
we are not boyfriends whatever whatever you want
to call us fine with me seriously we this guy has
no filter he's the worst oh Simon hit him hit him
hit him I just wanted to say that I was sorry
okay I I no you're not I got a lot of [__]
for homecoming and I wanted everyone to focus on
something else you know I I just didn't think it
was you have no excuse I'm supposed to be the
one that decides when and where and how and who
knows and how I get to say it that's supposed
to be my thing and you took that away from me
so look can you please just get the away from
me that's right great you suck great line great
delivery oh oh no I saw the posts I know who
you are Jac I'm sorry Simon I can't do this
anymore no you can't leave me alone everything's
falling apart uh BL blocked him or you got rid
of his email one or the other permanently that
means it has to be someone at his school right
probably that's
awful you never got to know I don't think it's
him hey hey Simon are you blue no no it's not me
sorry all right now I'm convinced it is that
Gardener guy from the beginning maybe we don't
get to find out who blue is yeah at the end of
the day it's I mean but even if we don't find out
I feel like that that guy who we thought it could
have been could be into Simon did you know I knew
you had a secret when you were little you were
so Carefree but these these the last few years
more and more it's almost like I could feel you
holding your breath as soon as you came out you
said Mom I'm still me I need you to hear this you
are still you Simon you are still the same son who
I love to tease and who your father depends on
for just about everything and you're the same
brother who always compliments his sister on her
food even may you get to to Exhale now Simon you
get to be more you than you have been in in
a very long time you deserve everything you
want [__] you
movie oh you got me oh that was so sweet oh my
God got you too yeah yeah all parents were that
wonderful right I fell in love with someone that
guy in the emails I love him and I knew that if
Martin leaked our emails it scare them I know what
I did was messed up my best friend I'm your best
friend then why did you come out to Abby and not
me I think it was easier known Abby for 6 months
known you for 13 years and I knew that if I told
you that everything was going to be different
understandable tell me about this guy you love
a this is so sweet oh so I call him blue he needs
to give his hug his son a hug and say I love you
yeah they need to have their conversation if that
does not happen I'm going to be very disappointed
how long have you know I was around 13 I'm sorry I
shouldn't have missed it no hey no all the stupid
jokes I know you didn't mean him it doesn't
matter I shouldn't have missed it I just want
you to know that I love you and I'm really proud
of you I wouldn't change anything about you oh
[__] hey stop
crying come
here that video for Mom coming good good
I need your help on it though can you
help me with that yes exactly damn yeah
damn this movie is touching it really is
H you never a combo with your sister did you guys
do this I didn't I just help it was [Music] mostly
damn they really love each other I can't believe
you did this I panicked and bought you a watch
you can give me something later that I can't get
in the store that's really gross guys just look
just look at baby be a it's so cute a recent post
on this very website declared that I was gay the
delivery left something to be desired but the
message is true I am gay for a long time I was
killing myself to hide first I thought it was
just a gay thing but then I realize no matter
what announcing who you are to the world is
pretty terrifying what if the world doesn't
like you couldn't ask for more Amazing Friends
a more understanding family but it would all be
so much better if I had someone to share it with
so blue do you think it was that football player
that but I know who you are I know you're funny
and thoughtful you choose your words carefully
and that they're always perfect a like I told you
at the very beginning I'm just like you so blue
after the play Friday at 10: you know where
I'll be no pressure for you to show up but I
hope you do because you deserve a great love
story too love Simon Simon I think it's that
football player the one she said it's fine
remember that one it's fine she said when uh
fine I think it's that one we we haven't met
him though is so maybe it could be that's my
prediction okay I'm going to go back to my
original guess of it being the dude who held
the party hey Simon hey do you want to go to
the carnival with us tonight H yes we're the
four best friends that anyone could have and will
never ever ever ever where did he say they were
going to meet up at the fountain or I thought I
know he said after the play right yeah I don't
remember what he said though we'll be right here
get [Music] him did he say on the ferris wheel
or so that should last a while oh in the ferris
whe okay I bet he's waiting for the other gay kid
where's Dana she'll love this oh jeez is subtle
with that [Applause] comment so much pressure
oh jeez I don't think he's going to show cuz he
put it out there and now everyone this is his a
big announcement now I think he will because
of what happened with the email being afraid
and now like hey I he's not I feel like he's
not going to show up for the ferriso but it'll
show up after the fact cuz he's not ready for the
public to see him okay it's your last ride ticket
buddy wait oh can I have my ticket Simon it's
me no the it's not no you're not no I'm not I
just this is this is so brutal I here I tell you
what um it's going to say no way I already knew
he wasn't this cap oh no I can't watch I can't
watch this babe no okay to wait wait I it I called
it I know I got a little excited good job it was
Wally West Aaron called it it's you it's me it's
always been me but that night at the party yeah
I was uh I was drunk and confused and it ended
like a minute after you saw it h I didn't think
you'd come me neither until I was walking towards
you I I didn't think I had it in me are you
disappointed that it's me [Music] no woo [Music]
he's been waiting for him hey have you seen
Creek Secrets there are six new confessions
all signed inspired they hate that I want to
be an actor I don't know if they'll ever be
proud of me Taylor met you inspired them
oh man now we got to get Leah someone to
love I'm enjoying this movie but I feel
like it's had like it's to end like five
times it's Lord of the Rings Return of the
King it's lord of the freaking Rings dude I
feel like it's keep on the verge of ending and
then keeps going but I'm that being said I'm
enjoying it it just tonally it feels that way
you buddy got the crew Everybody in all right
it's too beautiful a day so I think I'm going to
actually take us on a little Adventure they're
having their Ferris speler Day Off damn I want
to I feel so dumb what city are we in I have no
clue I think we've hit the ending I think so I
think I think that's uh a logical conclusion all
right reject Nation so today I want to share
something with you that has been a wonderful
addition to my health and fitness journey that
I discovered during the holidays and that is
liquid IV's hydration multiplier I'm down to
my very last packet and I'm freaking out but
it's okay I got more in the mail now a lot of
you have been so kind to notice how I've been
working on my physical health thank you for
all the compliments and one thing I learned
is that proper hydration is absolutely crucial
especially post-workout and pre-filming after
post-workout and my wife actually introduced
me to this product which is perfect because
we not only care about quality but a good taste
and quality product whether it's after a sweaty
workout or just after you know a good night out
you know what I'm saying efficient hydration and
replenishing electrolytes is key you just feel
better and it tastes fantastic I can't emphasize
that enough another thing I'm always on the
lookout for too is products that have zero sugar
or zero sugar added because that's one of my main
dietary restrictions throughout the week and they
of course got products that fit that description
that also tastes good too so yes thank you so much
so liquid IV hydration multiplier is in summary is
they are a non-GMO electrolyte drink that delivers
hydration into your bloodstream faster and more
efficient than water alone sometimes drinking a
whole gallon is not always efficient but in fact
it can provide the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water I'm also big on
efficiency plus it's packed with 11 essential
vitamins and we know vins are good for the body
it's vegan soy free gluten- free and dairy free
you can customize the water amount to your taste
again perfect for postn Recovery traveling or just
having a big night out you know what I mean no so
if you want a booster support for the channel and
booster hydration game go to liquid i.com and
use promo code regexs at checkout that's liquid
iv.com promo code Rejects and remember liquid
IV it's not a real IV sure feels like it so stay
hydrated stay healthy and let's keep crushing
those health and fitness goals together in the
year 2024 by the way if you guys are listening
to us on Spotify or apple if you don't mind we
would really appreciate it if you would give us a
rating it really does help us outon yes what did
you think of my constant interrupting and making
you upset I'm just kid what did you think of the
what did you think of the film I really liked
it I really liked it it had so much heart it
was funny it was even though I did predict some
things that isn't that's not an indicator of the
quality of how well the story unfolded I thought
it was just so Charming I Really they really cast
and wrote Simon is such an endearing character and
you understood everything he was going through and
the way he was feeling and they really put you
in his shoes and it's a story you can connect
to whether you are gay uh whether you are gay
or straight or or anything in the Spectrum you
know I feel like it's just a very human story
about acceptance cuz like you know we all have
things that we are going through or struggling
through whether it be coming out whether it be
dealing with eating disorders whether it be you
know whatever secret or or challenge you undergo
but the fact that you see somebody overcome that
over the course of this story and learning to not
well I think he he accepted the fact that he was
gay but worrying about the perception of how he
was going to be perceived by the people in his
life because he was afraid of change I thought
all of that was very um very poignant you know
and I can connect to being someone who you know
has a contentious relationship with change so it
was yeah it was great I yeah it's it's always a
good sign when a m movie can make me laugh make
me cry make me frustrated like it it invoked all
of the emotions over the course of whatever this
runtime was and yeah I've never seen this movie
obviously but I really really enjoyed it and I'm
happy that I had the experience and I'd recommend
it to other people yeah for sure never seen it
I've never even heard of it before today but
I'm glad uh we got to watch it it was a beautiful
Coming of Age story and uh I just thought all the
performances were fantastic and i' had only seen
this actor as well in Jurassic world so I had not
really gotten a taste of his acting range and I
just thought as you said I think the best word
to describe he gave such an endearing performance
and he was an endearing character as well and I
think like you said too he definitely you know was
accepting of himself but then he was just worried
about you know how other people were going to you
know were going to perceive him and as well as he
was afraid to scare off you know who uh the the
guy he was emailing which turned out to be Wally
West as we find out later on in the film so you
can understand that you know we live in a very
judgmental world and uh we even got a little taste
of that with I forgot the other character uh that
we met at the school that was all gay where he
said like yeah whenever we go to family events
my mother tells my grandp parents who are very
old-fashioned that I have a bunch of girlfriends
and it's like that's a real that's a real thing
that is a real thing and it's it's you know that's
just the world we live in where some people just
are not accepting the fact and you know to each
their own um I you know I don't agree with it but
it you know again to each their own but again I
just thought this was a very beautiful film uh
and like you said I I really felt that it just
did a good job of doing a good job of balancing
between uh the romance stuff and also with the
comedy and just giving a lot of levity uh between
the dramatic stuff because it was a very you know
difficult situation that Simon was going through
you know he was just again very also too just
worried about like how how his I mean because he
heard comments you know from his parent uh was his
dad specifically you know I mean uh making the
comment about I think he said fruity and stuff
like that uh so you know perception is reality and
hold on let me just make sure got her y just hit
the pause button there please on the bottom left
there I see it I see it it's this mouse is like
moving yeah yeah and I mean backwards That's goes
backwards okay now continue yeah no and I mean I
I understand again totally why and also too and
in fact by not you know being uh open about his
sexuality like you almost lost his friends in
the process because yeah he was so scared well
not only not only because so scared but because
that jerk Martin who had a little Redemption at
the end with the ferris well I know I still
didn't like him but a tiny bit of redemption
a tiny tiny bit of redemption and I did like that
one even though it was cringe I did like that one
moment in the waffle place where he W uh where
he was just saying like you deserve a damn hero
cringe but I did like it uh but um I just just
again I I I did appreciate the fact that um he
he he was afraid to come out there but again
the truth will usually come out and you know
again that that that sets up for that set up for
you know like what happened with his friends and
you know it he almost lost them in the process so
but I also love the fact too that that whole thing
that at the end where he inspired people to not be
afraid to show their feelings and who they are I
thought that was beautifully it's so beautiful
and I thought Greg berlan who I only know as a
producer for the CW verse I thought he did a hell
of a job directing this film the performance is
so so well done so endearing he killed it yeah
really yeah know it was it was really endearing
and I liked how it captured like it was it was a
movie that could talk about in an honest way but
also address those other perspectives on it you
know and like I think the the moment for me was
like seeing when he came out on Christmas watching
his Dad's reaction versus his mom's reaction and
his dad not knowing how to process it and his mom
seemingly accepting him from the jump and then I
know you got emotional at both parents part but I
think the the part that really got me uh in tears
was like you've been holding your breath for years
and I was like a man like someone was just like
holding something so tight that they they can't
breathe they can't um operate in in comfortability
because they have to hold something so near and
dear or something so oh not even treacherous
that's not the right word but like some something
that's so sensitive and and close to them and me
be able to live in Freedom like that I think
that's very um yeah it's it's very uh not not
admirable but the fact that his mom was able to
see him and that was beautiful yeah no those were
probably two I mean I I I love the whole movie
but those scenes were just so I mean just how
accepting his parents were especially his mom and
then his dad it's not that he wasn't accepting he
was just like he just didn't know how to react in
the moment just because he was expecting his son
to be this raging testosterone man to get all
the women kind of thing so it's just like and
again he was trying to deal with I think he said
it best like in the moment he was trying to deal
with it best with comedy and like joking around
like deflecting yeah exactly he was deflecting
for sure so uh but like to come back with him and
just say hey you're still my boy I still love you
like that was just so heartfelt so sweet I love
that and um again there were some really powerful
moments in in this uh film as well in terms of
you know how the Cobra Kai Chris the guy who
looks like Chris Brown and uh the other bully how
they were treating Simon and then the other kid uh
in school too uh how awful they were treating and
how insensitive and I love how that one teacher I
think it's the Cabaret teacher how she just did
the mic drop on them but it's it's just crazy we
live in a time I mean I've never I to to really
be blunt with you guys I actually dealt with uh
being uh I was bullied myself in Middle School not
for the same reason uh it was not about sexuality
just I was just bullied um so I can understand
you know what Simon was going through again not
for the same reasons just being bullied it sucks
it's not fun at all um although difference being
as I was physically bullied whereas uh Simon was
being mentally uh bullied but still either way
they both are terrible um but it's just again just
so crazy to me we live in a society where not all
but some people can get to a point where they feel
that's necessary a lot of times too that can be a
ramification of just the craziness that's going
on in their own minds and you know what they're
dealing with and then you know they bring it
into the world for um you know because again
what they're you know what's going on in their
lives and I feel bad for them I really do yeah uh
it sucks uh and I wish them well uh and get the
help that they need um because we should all be
accepting of you know if it it doesn't affect your
life so I don't know why you have to you know get
on other people for things you know even if you
don't agree it's they they likely like they feel
small at home so they got to make other people
feel small make themselves so big you know the
usual bully thing yeah and if you don't agree hey
that's your business it's all good like keep it
to yourself no worries like you don't have to get
on someone else for something you don't agree with
that's that's fine uh all good you know we're
not all going to agree with everything in this
world and you know that's what makes the world
go around but you don't need to bring someone
else down to uplift yourself is kind of all I'm
saying um God I just want to punch Martin still
um anyway but hey he he gave a great I thought
that actor like he was so annoying but he gave
a great performance he did he did his job he made
me cringe he made me mad so I'm like Kudos too you
played that role very well yeah I don't want
to see you I don't want to see that character
in real life but hey yeah great giv no but hey
seriously though Beautiful film uh and again I
really appreciate it I think his name was Zack
Robinson the main actor who played Simon great
performance fantastic seriously great I mean it's
a very difficult job to uh be the lead in a film
and I thought and drama yeah he really carried
the film you could see how much weight like just
what he was holding within him and just like to
to still like be such a a wonderful kind human
being and you know with everything that he was
withholding within himself like I just really love
this character so much and I'm so glad I I got to
uh watch this film was a really good one and again
so impressed with Greg perlan I didn't even know
he was a director so uh I was really impressed
stick to dramas Greg yeah stick to stick to stuff
like this you know I mean you had to run in the
superhero world but like you did a good job into
by the way but uh yeah I'm very impressed with him
as a director do you have any final thoughts you'd
like to say if not did your did your brain also do
that thing like when you're watching it I was just
like what what superhero would he play what comic
book character would he play are you talking about
Simon yeah oh uh I didn't say that but I mean I'm
usually always saying stuff like that every
time I see like a young leading actor I'm like
what kind character would you play I know I with
his performance in this film he he could do any
type of I mean he really showed me a lot of acting
range in this film he was F he was fantastic great
Peter Parker I could see it I was act okay yep you
got me there no when he had his glass when he had
his glasses on at that dance and the woman and the
girl said to him I love you and he's like and then
he went into the bathroom and told his mom that
uh uh there's drugs or drinks at the party like
come get me or something actually was thinking
Peter Parker no joke I really was I'm not just
agreeing with you to agree with you I really did
say that in my head you just reminded me of that
I really was thinking that good call anyways what
did you guys think of the film love Simon um love
to hear your thoughts in the comments section
below are there other films like this or other
films just in general that you would like Aaron
myself other members of the real rejects to react
to we'd love to hear your thoughts down below
and we wish you all a wonderful New Year and take
care Tyler he happy New Year buddy now a friendly
reminder to everyone who hasn't heard this yet
Tyler hey he gave us a uh I gave me not us sucker
dead beat yeah you haven't once touched the PS5
it's actually a four that he gave me remember
that's right it was a PS4 well see how much
I know I got the PS4 and then you got so I could
play Red Dead Redemption too now at the beginning
of that time it would became a really daunting
experience and I got sidetracked beat plenty
of other games on that new system but uh did not
be red dead and then randomly over the holidays
I was like you know what I'm going to pick up Red
Dead too cuz I need a a game that I could just get
lost in the world for sure and dude I've stuck
to it at least a couple times a week I've been
playing uh after usually really late at night to
wind down the M I got a really unhealthy habit
what I do is I take a melatonin so I can get
tired but if I just lay there with melatonin
I don't get tired I need to distract my brain so
take a melatonin I play a game stimulate my mind
with these brain waves of truns and headphones on
and then I get tired and I fall asleep and I have
a Restless sleep and I'm like oh my God I'm all
groggy what the hell but at least I was asleep
but I actually got to bed though yeah like 3 in
the morning get it work sure so uh yeah man and
I'm on i' I've officially gone way further past
where I last left off years ago so uh because I
started all over again and so man I'm just going
to keep you upd on the journey it's been a great
journey with it and I hope in 2024 uh the next
time you're out in Cali you best bet I'm going
to make the time to meet up with you as long
as it's not like a half hour away if you're
in like a 20 minute range we could that's but if
you're more than 30 minutes I don't even know who
you are I don't like do things exist 30 minutes
from here I'm going to forget about why I care
to meet up with you in that time frame I extra 10
minutes I get so distracted will be cleared I get
so distracted by the stress of losing that amount
of time cuz time is money man time is money time
is valuable all right that's why we charge $130 on
Cameo that's right people get that that's and then
we record like a 40 minute long you know video and
I don't understand why we get no cameos now you
know people are weak and they $20 to 130 people
they just don't think that they're worthy of such
a good came that was a good gradual build honestly
um but Tyler man uh what is new's resolution be
Tyler's New Year's resolution should be uh to line
every surface in his house with screens if anybody
could do it because then you could get into the
Guinness Book of World Records and then you could
pretty much retire off that and also ride like
the notoriety to get you know like free access
to like most things in life so if you became
like the guy with the most TVs coding every
surface in his home find a couple creative ways
to like you know morph doors and things like you
know that could really be your key to Mor doors
porest Mor doors the porest floors there a chorus
s over my I don't know what speaker system
rymes with bores bors yeah Mor mors LS Norse
Norse with my my Norse horse with the force
of Norse horse on the back of a horse with
no remorse no remorse killing people to
the floors that's an awfully hot coffee
pot oh that's going to be my goal for 2024
Tyler is uh is to get good enough at Eminem
freestyling that I'm always ready to go 16
bars worth of random lyrical Miracle word
salad all righty buddy I guess this
was your shout out love you [Music]